[Music]
and we love I I man I Trail off there
and I said we love the come I love the
come
on that's okay that now you're just
saying weird so honestly SEC secet
yeah go go
Mark oh how did you get over there [__]
[Music]
so
no oh my God I wait the loop what do you
mean there's a Spider
ohly Man I
have
what is that by loud horn
oh I want to I want to be I
be why is way
dead what what what what
what oh H ring the Horn of the damn um I
don't
know interesting uh well I'll I you want
to go in I guess Mark do what I I you
want to you want to do it yeah let's do
it all we're going
right
anyway
okay oh my God oh my God oh my God oh my
God oh my God oh my God oh my God oh my
God oh my
[Music]
God you all
right what
oh I think we're supposed to be quiet
but was that real I think so is it
gone um it's not on the map I'm just
going to go I'm going to go okay I'm
going wait Mark we still don't know why
Wade even died I don't either but I feel
like
we
but
what B Bob
wait Mark Mark Bob what happened to you
what what happened to you I'm inside are
you all
right yeah I'm
good I'm really good
sure
yeah I'm fine have you always been
inside the
[Music]
building FL be on the ground we get down
let's
go
oh this is the we don't want to go back
there oh my God I'm dead I'm a dead man
I every nothing is okay where are you
where am I I I found my way out but what
I'm coming back to the ship come back to
the ship there's a creature by the ship
I everything is bad everything is bad
well I found a hammer inside maybe
that'll help yeah maybe that'll help
maybe that'll help just be aware there's
some kind of weird bad
creature how how how
bad I don't I think it's
gone are we good there there's a there's
a Rover there's a
Rover what do you what is that what do
you mean dog okay it's not by the ship
any I'm going to come in I it looks fine
I think it's fine Mark I'm going to come
ins come in come in come me out come in
are you in
here
[Music]
you dude there's nothing out there it's
fire so we need to leave we need to
leave I we need to
[Music]
leave I'm terrifying sure I never should
have B the horn no I like the horn the
horn is the horn is cursed us the horn
is good I like the horn the horn is
cursed us we need to leave we need to
leave whoa be under you if arue you're
not moving anymore I don't trust
you I'm it's fine it's fine let's go
then should we go let's go we need to
leave we need to leave okay dude you are
you feeling okay you're actually pretty
insane actually I don't understand
anything that's happening
anymore let's just go to the next area
and we'll go inside and hopefully Wade
won't die I don't even know if I can
trust you right now I don't know if I
can tress anything right now what I'm
we're in the ship in space like there's
the ship is not even a safe place
anymore nothing is safe Wade's dead he
died in the ship oh God here's something
[__] weird
Okay perspective there's like a dog
walking of the ship like clipping in Bob
coming from outside nothing there is
there is Mark huc like not like in real
life in the game dude I don't Mark
hallucinating have no idea
I mean how did you get into this be fair
this mod pack is one that I used but I
didn't make it so I don't know what all
is in it but Mark I mean there was
legitimately a dog's face clipping in
behind I know I know but there was I
literally just walked up in and walked
into the ship there was nothing yeah how
did you get into the building well okay
that I actually don't know I just like
teleported in yeah it was like he got
teleported in but we don't have a tele
we don't even own a teleporter can we
buy yeah I don't understand anything was
legitimately freaked because I couldn't
tell what was real I was not okay yeah
so I was watching Bob and I thought you
were just like freaking the [__] out
over my death oh sorry how did you die
the dog how did you die how did you die
you just died I was walking out and then
like I heard a noise I turned around and
just [__]
exploded weird there was like a weird
tune and then I just exploded we love
the comp do we want to go back to f want
to go back there why would we go back
it's a terrible place I mean Fair fair's
fair all we can go back I'm I'm not a
coward it's it's just it's supposed to
be scary Mark I think you're just are
you all right yeah well we're stormy so
just be careful with metal I was oh I I
would not bring a shovel I am leaving
the shovel who put the hammer in the or
just be prepared to drop it a lot that
that was on your dead body yeah this
actually I think maybe that's causing
the hallucinations I we were supposed to
like turn it in last time so I don't
know yeah it's like glitching through
the floor oh well I thought we we're
here just watch out for lightning bolt
all right lightning bolts it
is walk's on walk's
on walk's on walkie on
boys whoa oh okay I thought there was
like a swamp it's just the
rock ah
weird all
right let's do this
weeh hello hello what Bob hi hello Bob
how are you doing
that I I just ran to the entrance what
did what how how where did you guys go I
was following you and I just ran the
took the broken metal wait I saw
something else here but how did you get
in that room
I I was I just went over there I was in
here for like 30 seconds before you guys
even showed up what the [__] how what do
you mean what that mean I don't what you
were you're how are you so slow I don't
know I don't we stopped I don't think we
stopped we no we didn't stop we didn't
stop at
all
where did everyone
go oh my God yeah I went out I went out
I'm
okay okay all of a sudden it got dead
silent
oh
what the [__] was
that Mark you
good oh my
jeez okay wait did Mark just die I don't
know what was the static what is
happening I just got hecking teleported
where are
you oh hey where are you I'm above I'm
above you oh okay oh hey okay I thought
I thought you were next to me I was like
what that was close but not quite I've
got a whole bunch of keys but I found
like No Loot in here where did he did he
go back at the main
entrance I would I guess I I really have
no idea I don't even know where the uh
the fire exits are I I guess I don't
either oh God I'm going to go risk this
might blow up then try have
fun
this just wraps back
[Music]
around what is w freezing why does he
ohoh I don't understand why Bob just
Freez Bob I found the
uh yeah I I found the apparatus room oh
all right
we grab it and go we haven't really got
that much loot though I I I haven't seen
a single
thing uh I mean do we want to find Mark
maybe
first yeah Mark are you
okay I really don't think he's okay no I
think he's dead but I have no idea what
the [__] happened why am I talking
through
Bob are you there yeah okay um I mean
let's just get the do you know the way
out from here sorry do you know the way
out from here very roughly should we
apparatus and just get the hell out of
here
sure
H
why why
isod uh I don't know you should have
been more confident about this yeah
that's oh no okay okay
spider I'm
injured I
think yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah here yeah yeah no no no
no not the way I went the way you're
went what I'm at the
entrance please prepare for emergency
evacuation bomb coming from outside
nothing there explosion IM F
immediately oh [__] oh
God hey hello uh yeah I got
lightning
oh that's not idea yeah I thought it
would only happen once so I picked the
things back up I didn't realize that it
would almost immediately strike me again
over
not my God what the [__] yeah that
happened to me everything went wrong
every that that happened to me I kept I
kept like I dropped things and I didn't
expect it to happen
twice oh that explains the static over
the yeah the radio uh you're like yeah
guys I went
outside yeah that that that was uh it
didn't go great all right we have one
day to make
$149 we got to make the best this got to
be the best run of our life boys I
Believe in Us really does we're going to
March we're going to March here's what
we do here's the plan boys you ready for
the plan yes yeah what we're going to do
is we're going to all run in grab the
first thing we see if it's two it's
great that's good get back to that ship
and then we're going to have one man in
the ship or something I don't actually
know what the right plan
is
wait all run in and get stuff yeah I was
making it up to F huh yeah should run
point and ship right that's good I was I
was literally like making it up it was
kind of like confidence just carrying me
through okay it's not Stormy this time
we're going boys we're going on walkie
on I don't have a flashlight hold on
that's
bad walkie on I'm going through the back
uh fire
exit
[Music]
oh damn
you go on in I'm in I got two things
[Music]
already I just found a gold bar worth
190 oh
[__] you better get that
back oh go
away yeah I kind of feel like I should
just get that back right
away all right believe it or not I'm
full up
boys
oh God I don't
remember oh God which one was it oh God
I don't remember which fire exit I came
on there's two right next to each other
stupid loot bug go away hey if you have
a shovel I heard a hoing bug I need to
kill a hoing bug for a I think it'll
drop a gold bar if we kill
it well I got two here they're annoying
uh can you when you get back to the ship
can you tell me which one is which what
the fre no I be able to tell which one
you to kill him will tell me do you have
a shovel no the fire exit I'm next to
have two fire exits oh yeah yeah I can
tell you one
second what the freak what the freak oh
God they're mad oh they're mad oh my God
please hurry please
hurry oh my God both of them are real
they're both real oh okay okay
okay oh my God hey hi I just SP a braen
like he's like 2 in for
me um and you're
alive he I saw him and he was like Wow
and then he
left is there anything useful
way uh one second I'm being pursued by
pe Mar and Wayne are talking to me from
the other side of this door I don't
believe it I don't like yeah that's uh
probably not us um just be careful about
that you got two red
dots okay yeah Bracken um do you need a
door open
somewhere uh yeah no thank you that's
the one all right wait if I read out
these doors you you can you help him I
already open them what
about yeah you're good you're good
Wade's on computer I'm watching you
through keep going you can um you can
use the monitor the map both are real
both are real
I don't have anything crap you can use
that and see the map too Mark you don't
have to go back and forth oh I wasn't
but it's all good I'm going to go to
that fire and try to kill theing bu cuz
I need it okay you want me to come with
or do you need to kill it oh yeah we
could two man it just in case something
else comes along okay yeah I'll gra to
come back in and try to kill a hoarding
bug together cuz maybe it'll drop a gold
bar we need the money yeah we need that
last we don't make it if we don't make
it Bob uh there's a a nest a b nest on
the front of the ship after you take off
run out grab it and take it in it's
worth 169 yeah all
right all right let's kill this I am one
hit away from Death By the way that's
not it where am I I'm lost I I went the
wrong way where am I I don't know I'm
right by the ship I was yelling for
you I went for the exit I I took a wrong
turn I don't know where I am
the ship's to your
right watch the hole looks like there's
a hole there yeah there's holes oh I see
one bunker I'm going to just take it and
go in did you go in main or
fire fire they're at the
fire wait wait are you inside or
outside I just ran by you outside I'm
getting ready to run inside oh okay good
ow there's a Bracken at the fire exit
FYI I'm going into a fire exit Mark I
don't know which one you went in but I'm
coming in all right there's a I'm
dead I'm a dead man goodbye please take
care of chica she's such a good girl
what do you mean you're dead I'm inside
where are you I'm outside but my demise
is occurring
presently
Bob is dead we need to go and we need to
get we need to get that those be which
direction is the arrow pointing which
way is the ship from me to your
left
keep going that
way slight left whenever you get no too
far
left yep keep going that
way it's not following you're
good jump in jump in we got to go we got
to
go uh I'm ready you want me to hit the
switch Yeah okay hitting the switch
if you're ready you ready hit
it get in get in get in get in get in
get in get in get in get in get in get
in get in oh my
godive holy [__] there's the other
beehive get in get
in Oh I Think We Made
It Maybe not maybe not even close hey
guys how's it going hi hey hey what's up
man hey good to see you oh what happened
to the be you had I died to
be did not make it back to we
63 we already have 98 though uh if I
math that correctly we're like 20 or $30
short it's okay we got no we got we got
this we got this we just got to we got
this I've got yeah we we yes oh yeah oh
yeah oh oh so good yeah we're so good
we're so good shs don't sell for no no
no I'm not I'm not that's not what I'm
doing that's not what I'm doing that's
not what I'm doing see we just got to
charm them uh just let me do the
talking hi or should I say hello
everybody yeah it's me Mark BL hey uh
listen um we need a solid here can you
give us a loner man you have such
beautiful eyes I think that
worked yeah yeah oh yeah I feel really
good about it Mark okay good yeah good
you should
we still have $15 in this [__] oh
it
h hey what's up uh
listen love your eyes love your thighs I
love it when you tell me
lies
so all
right oh zero zero that's I feel like
that it said six and then it said zero I
feel like it should have hey guys I got
us some consolation prizes uh-huh
oh oh yeah oh hell yeah oh hell yeah
four of them for all four of us nothing
bad can happen now that we have this
this is the B oh room okay
oh why my face oh wa wa whoa take some
doing whoa
whoa does it hurt every time you use it
oh oh oh oh oh god oh it hurts every
time you
crash oh wait wait wait easy peasy Mark
yeah what's up I got this control no
you're good you seem fine yeah you seem
really
good oh Mar
yeah ow why did that hurt why did that
hurt so bad yeah it it hurts like ever I
think Wade's dead already
okay hey wait a minute wait I see we're
going to get through this
guys where you you go Bud Mark we're
getting through this where you going
we're we're going to get through this
yeah thought I saw something up here
that we could sell turns out we didn't
all right uh hey wait can we sell Wade's
dead body yeah wait oh yeah oh yeah oh
how much is that worth yeah that's got
to be worth something excuse me
sir ooh here you know what Mark I'm
going to help you out how what do you
mean I'm going to help you out
H oh there's no more fuel in Wades
either well that's just annoying I think
I think he might have blowed
it
uh
fascinating
W well that's not probably enough you
know what man you know why this is why
that it's because it's because these
[__] here just don't understand what
it is to do hard work they wouldn't
oh oh hi hi they wouldn't understand A
Hard Day's work if it if it what okay
they wouldn't understand A Hard Day's
Work Hey Hey Hey listen here
Hey listen to me listen to me you
[__] don't give us enough money for
all the work
that
PO fascinating uh I can't grab these
anymore hey hey hey you you listen here
buddy you can take my friend and you can
take my freedom but you can't take my
love of this
company
um you are true
professionals am I too handsome for
this hey
hey
hey damn too incredibly good-looking for
them to eat me
fascinating all right
whatever good thing we made quota uh
they can't blast me out the airlock if I
stay in my paranoia
Corner oh
hey guys
$6,000 in
fin that's okay we
have, we
have oh [__] what you doing back there
uh you know holding on
our the
company sness of the company so um so uh
hosting the next
distractable uh-huh a good segue that
segue that's a great segue yep that's a
good one if you want more of us
interacting with a fun good time you
need to check out distractable we mean
that click the link in the description
or the link in the card over there try
out an episode for yourself it's highly
recommended by everyone in the comments
everyone in the comments please
recommend your favorite episode there's
like actually over a 100 episodes for
you to check out there's a lot of fun
stuff we have that how many episodes
have we made it's a lot of episodes it's
a lot of episodes one of the comments
tell us how many episodes we have you
can't just make the comments do
everything for you someone in the
comments I have gotten by 12 years of
this career by not doing a thing I will
continue to do so if you want more of
Wade not doing a thing and us uh also
not doing a thing check out distractable
I feel like we do lots of things oh we
do not distractable we do do do many
things we do now I want to ski do which
means I want to be the
water e cracking me
up okay all right it's a lot funnier
undestructible
[Music]